JLo you're gonna get to see her tonight
and you're here at the Super Bowl
hanging with her tell me about your
whole relationship and how it came about
with JLo so a couple years ago I decided
that my dream is to dance with JLo this
this is Charlie's vision board what are
we looking at here talked about her in
almost every interview I've done
whenever they ask what my biggest dreams
are and she's super talented I got to
see her in concert actually got to see
her twice because the first time is when
the power went out in New York City so
we got to see it twice and my dream was
to go to University of Las Vegas beyond
their dance team because their
choreographers are jealous
choreographers and then like I had
everything planned out and yesterday I
got to meet and dancer for the first
time so it was really a dream come true
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how was that getting to dance with JLo
finally and how nervous were you at
first when I first met her and I got to
shake her hands and I was just blank
face I didn't know what to say and then
it kind of set in and tears just started
rolling down my eyes cuz this is all I
ever really really wanted to experience
and it happens and it was really really
crazy okay so you get in there you're
ready to dance you count off and then
what goes through your brain as you're
getting ready to dance with JLo so I
have learned the JLo Super Bowl
challenge before because that's what
they had said I wanted to do so I was
ready and at first you can even see it
in the video that she posted like I got
nervous and I forgot to dance at first
but we repeated it twice the second time
I got it and I was just so so excited
and her dancers actually there some of
them are Paris Global's dancers who I've
also been falling for a very long time
because they're all crazy talented and
Tiffany Maher was there so it was like
one big dance dreams all coming through
at one what is your dream job one day
where's all this go I obviously want to
be a dancer in some way because that's
been my dream forever Dancing with JLo
doing something similar to what Jayla
does maybe it's just there's so many
opportunities that
are being presented to you right now I
just want to try everything and see what
works there legitimately crazy
what's been the wildest response you've
gotten from someone what's been the
wildest thing that's happened so it's
actually when I was here so this girl
she could see what hotel I was in from
the videos I was posting and she came
the first day and she just started
crying and I got to meet her three times
and she's the sweetest little girl she's
like this tall she's probably like nine
or ten years old every time I saw her
she was just crying and I was like
please don't cry and today I actually
told her I was like can you promise me
not to cry I just I feel so bad I just I
was giving her all the hugs I could
because I just felt so bad and she was
like this is your my JLo and I was just
like that's how could that ever be
possible without tick tock it's really
that's just my heart and it was such a
good feeling to know that how I feel
about JLo someone feels about me that's
pretty crazy
[Music]